coming as portrayed many characters over
the decades long career his roles
include a James Bond villain in
Goldeneye a mutant in x-men 2 and a
political operative in the good life now
he's taking on a new role in the CBS
drama instinct coming plays dr. Dylan
Reinhardt a former CIA operative and
college professor who ends up helping
New York police after a killer starts
planning crimes based on his book I have
a feeling there'll be more murders which
is why I'm here before Dino died the
killer sent your book to the Homicide
Division as the famous expert on
criminal psychopathology I was hoping
you might have some ideas don't they
call you professor psychopath well I may
have a fascination in the sexy past it
does not mean I am one I'm judging by
the way you eat your pizza I'm not so
sure using a fork and knife slows the
process down and allows you to focus
more on the pizza itself I'm no problem
focusing on pizza you should try it
sometime sure right after I catch
whoever killed this kid inside Alan
[ __ ] is also an executive producer of
the show we welcome you back to the
table everybody knows you don't eat
pizza well then I've got a four gallon
but this is what's so cool about you we
were talking about you in the makeup
room this morning people said oh I
remember him from Spy Kids I remember
him x-men yeah remember cabaret because
I'm wanted that's what it is
your last role was a good wife and I
read that you said I don't know if I
want to do another TV show that you had
some reluctance into taking this part
yes well you know it's good life came to
an end and I'm very sanguine about these
things I think things should end you
know but I think in America but just
what try to keep things going and going
and going
holding on yeah yeah and so I was I
thought it was a nice ending and then I
thought oh is this nice I'll now be
going back to being a peripatetic actor
you know on stage on the stage and then
around the world you know doing films
and blah blah and I did that for like a
year then this I was in Edinburgh
actually working in Edinburgh when I got
the the initial sort of salvo about this
job and actually I just suddenly thought
this is too good a thing to pass up on
you know you know I was it too good just
did it with so many different facets of
a character and I was sort of I mean
he's got so many different
characteristics and actually I think if
you when you think about going into a
long running potentially long running
you want to make sure you don't get
boards yes Blaine who dr. Dylan
Reinhardt his so he's a when you meet
him he's a college professor a rather
idiosyncratic one little bit of a dandy
he and then you and he's written a book
that is a bit best-seller but abnormal
behavior and could be good Berg please
my long-suffering editor and then he's
also a former CIA spy and naturally and
then and he's a farmer musical child
prodigy and he has Phonographic memory
things for him that's what I like that's
what I mean two things about the gay
thing one I've thought this is the first
ever Network drama on American
television to have a gay character as
the lead and I thought about when you
were about blooming time yeah and I want
to be a part of that and also the gay
thing is like exactly the fourth or
fifth thing you see at the character and
I think that's a big step because mostly
when gay people are on network
television
I think it's been treated in and I have
a husband played by this nice tactical
Dining's and I just really thought that
was handled really really well and I and
I think it's a you know good on CBS for
finally doing this started James
Patterson book he's been here a number
of times he yeah he's it's so funny
because I didn't know it's kind of like
a mystery I'd met him yeah and had a
lovely chat with him unbeknownst to me
that it was him right yeah yeah maybe
drinking involved and then then I got
this book the first got a galley copy of
the book to read to see if that's
interest and I was like wow you know
reading this mister not my normal thing
but I was really when I was in Edinburgh
doing this thing I said who wrote this
and my manager said the person who sells
one in every 17 books that are sold in
America yeah he says one in 17 books
yeah I know I think it's interesting you
didn't know who he was and hadn't read
his books we go hey this guy's pretty
good
yeah well certainly
page-turner you recently opened up club
coming yes my body nice you said that's
your greatest achievement I think it's
my greatest artistic achievement because
I wanted a place to have a spirit where
everybody would feel welcome and all
ages all genders all sexualities and
calm and kindness would be a thing and
performance and dancing and and it
actually has happened this worked that's
why it's your greatest achievement yeah
mission accomplished thank you thank you
congratulations I think you got another
hitting on you
fingers crossed you can watch series
premiere of instinct Sunday night at
8:00 7:00 central right here on CBS only
CBS